dans un instant d'abord les révoltes
dans le monde arabe et une fois n'est
pas coutume ce n'est pas par la Libye
que nous commençons ce soir mais par la
Syrie qui bascule à son tour dans une
répression sanglante les forces de
sécurité de Bachar el-Assad auraient
tiré sur la foule des manifestants il y
aurait au moins 15 morts ces dernières
24 heures Philippe
Rochot voitures incendiées tir à balle
réelle de la police contre des
manifestants lors des funérailles de
deux personnes trois morts à nouveau
aujourd'hui dans cette ville de deaha à
100 km au sud de Damas du jamais vu dans
cette syérie tenue par la main de fer du
parti bass au pouvoir depuis 40 ans les
manifestants ont attaqué les locaux du
parti dominés par la figure du président
Bachar el-Assad sa famille issue d'une
minorité chiite dirige le pays depuis 45
ans ils ont également incendié les
locaux de la compagnie de téléphone
Syriatel tenu par un cousin du président
dénonçant la corruption du régime le
limogage du gouverneur ne change pas
grandchose à la détermination des
manifestants qui récl l'élargissement
des prisonniers politiques et plus de
liberté le régime syrien décare à qui
veulent entendre qu'il s'agit d'un gang
à la solde de l'étranger qui avait caché
des armes à la mosquée au mari et qui a
fait feu sur la police le pouvoir
annonce que des réformes sont en cours
elles seront insuffisantes pour calmer
un vent de contestation sans précédent
qui se met à souffler sur la
Syrie